la siguiente igualdad de proporciones es
cierta o falsa y nos dicen que 312 abós
o sea la proporción 3 a 12 es igual a
535 abós o sea la proporción 5 a 35
bueno pues para determinar si esta
igualdad se da lo que tenemos que hacer
es ver si estas dos fracciones son
fracciones equivalentes y una forma de
hacer eso es simplificar las y ver si
nos da lo mismo entonces déjame empezar
simplificando 312 ambos aquí le voy a
poner 3 aquí 12 y aquí voy a poner un
poquito de espacio
bueno notemos que el numerador y el
denominador son ambos divisibles entre 3
vamos a dividirlos entre 3 para
simplificar aquí entre 3 y aquí entre 3
3 entre 3 es igual a 1 y abajo nos queda
12 entre 3 que es igual a 4 muy bien
entonces aquí está la primera fracción
simplificada ahora veamos qué sucede con
5 entre 30 y 55 entre 30 y 55 entre 35
pues aquí tanto el numerador como el
denominador son divisibles entre 5 y si
dividimos entre 5 en 35 entre 5 en él
nos queda 5 entre 51 y en el denominador
nos queda 35 entre 5 o sea 7 entonces
está igualdad de proporciones es lo
mismo a pedir que un cuarto un cuarto
sea igual a un séptimo a un séptimo y
esto es claramente falso entonces esta
igualdad de proporciones es falsa